CBS News has confirmed there's been a
second deadly accident this week
involving servicemembers on a training
exercise 21 year old marine private
first class christian bautista was
killed on Sunday military officials say
Bautista died when a vehicle he was
enrolled over at a Marine Corps training
facility in Bridgeport California that
same day three army troops died at Fort
Stewart in Georgia they were sergeant
first class Brian Andrew Jenkins
corporal Thomas Cole Walker and private
first class antonio gilbert garcia they
died when their Bradley Fighting Vehicle
a vehicle like this one here rolled over
their divisions commanding general
struggled to hold back tears as he
described what happened I would like to
offer my sincere condolences to the
family members of the three soldiers
that we lost and yesterday's tragic
accident it is hard enough when you lose
one soldier but when you lose three at
one time that pain is amplified
according to a recent congressional
report there were nearly twice as many
active-duty service members killed in
accidents than in combat between 2006
and 2008 eeen